Cambridge, you have to remember, had all kinds
of factories when I was a kid growing up.
We had Lever Brothers, we still have a little
bit of Necco, but you had all kinds of little
shops. And probably one of the most notable
one, they had a donut shop on Main Street.
And you could always smell the donuts. They
still have Paul's, which is a corner store,
and even though we grew up and left, people
still come back to Paul's just for a sub.
Primarily a meatball sub, because no one makes
a better meatball sub than Paul's Variety
down on School Street. Cambridge was just
so wonderful, so memorable growing up. If
there was ever an all-American city it would
have to have been Cambridge. Of course you
would've had to have been here to know that,
to experience it, and to appreciate it. I
went to Roberts School which is called the
Maynard now, it's on the corner of Windsor
and Harvard Street. I lived in that community
all my life. When you're a young man, a little
kid, it's a big school. All my friends went
there. When we went to school, you'd go in
the morning and come home at lunch, then go
back in the afternoon. Everybody in the community
that I lived in went there. I've got to tell
you, we lived in more of a multicultural community.
There were the [family name]s who were Greek,
there were the [family name]s who were Greek.
There was Roseanne and they were Italian,
and there were Portuguese, people from Barbados,
the Harris's, Steven Harris and his family,
Humphrey Harris. And we wandered between the
two projects [name of housing development]
and Newtowne Court. Down there at the gardens,
down by St. Mary's, and we wanders to St.
Mary's, where we grew up with Timmy Boylan,
a lot of the Irish kids that went to the Catholic
school, the Cape Verdean kids. We were a multicultural
community. It was a community where the statement
today is "It takes a village to raise a family."
We were that village.